Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to: "You Left Me".
Now, this is a serious game about a serious topic,
that doesn't mean that its not gonna have laughs,
that doesn't mean its not gonna have interesting moments
but i have just been told that this game is relatively serious.
So, we are gonna get right into it and move right along.
It's one of those games where you go through, learn the story, and there is multiple endings to it.
So...
We gotta wake up.
Hello?
Ah. Oooh.
Work.
Wake up. Work. Sleep.
Wake up.
The next day I woke up in the same bed but a different world.
Where am I? Why am I here? I
I don't know. nice guy-ooUUugh
Nice okay
Sounds like I'm underwater. Oh, oh on the moon clicks a 12-hour timer
What happens when night falls,
when time runs up?
How do I get out of here before then?
How do- whyy am I in a hand? Oh
Okay, hi kitty, Ohahaha you gave me this cat I love him like you had
Around him. I feel comfortable no need to pretend. Yeah?
Hm, something doesn't seem right. Maybe it's a big glowing eye in the middle of his face,
But I can't I remember how he looks up close.
I haven't spent time with him not since
I'm gonna talk to him. Hello, uh, ooh
What did I name my cat? I've had him for a while now yet, I can't remember
Senior Waff-
Doggo?
Senior waffles is good, but I gotta go with doggo. Hey doggo the cat *chuckles*
Hey kitty-catty doggo-woggo, how you doin'?
I'm pretty proud of that one, thought of it myself.
I did. Hey doggo. Oh you pee everywhere. But I love you anyway.
Moo moo Bork! Mah duuuude
mah duude
You're awake. Good snug last night!
Oh...
Alright, how do I get out of here?  Meow? This isn't normal I don't belong here. Is that bad?
Normal isn't always a good thing, you know?
Aw
Pat.
bork blork blorf borph
aAaAAAhhHH
All right, scritch scratch boof burrff, stpbeduff.
I will marry you platonically. I love *chuckle* you
Thank yoiyyj
I'll leave you to sleep now. Yip ruff, Yis mam i stan
You make me happy nay
I heart
Heart you too
Oh
Moo moo moo. Hee-haw, you're leaving already
Okay. Love you. Please come back soon for purrs and snugs
All right
Love you, too. Oh
Okay, it's now 8:44
What does that mean my phone?
Unseen text missed calls. I rarely look at my phone anymore. I try to forget about the memories it contains
How does the pancake wobble? Read notes. Hmm?
White messages read and
[Random words]
Okay. They read, they read
[More random words]
I'm trying but I can't read them. I see words, but I don't understand what they mean
Try again, I
I don't know what's going on. I feel like my mind is working against me. I can't focus
It can't stop thinking about horrible things. I feel like I'm going crazy. Oh
I'm not scared of failure. Try again. That's me. That is me
After a few attempts I get it. Oh
Okay, how does the pancake wobble the magnets ask?
The first sticky note reads: daily reminder. I love you from you-know-who not the Harry Potter kind
The second note reads..
Reads
Remember: Swain's Lane. Why? The third note reads give this girl some milk.
Alright, that's enough fridging i guess.
it's still 8:44 so I guess I could look inside
The fridge? I'm positive there's nothing. Look anyway, I found my keys in the freezer
I thought I'd put them in my pocket. How'd that get there? Did I put them there?
I need to get my memory checked. I don't know how you do that. But okay. All right, I guess that's enough for today
Uhh
Clock? The moon rumbles. That's not something that the moon should do!
Just thinkin-thunklin about it about myself. Get out of bed. Oh
I am on a rocket ship to space. Where do I go? I need to escape this world before time runs out.
Ahh
What's going on outside I haven't noticed before now Ever wueew
Okay, every day the bus passes the same flower field. You would've like this. I wish I could show this to you. Oh, all right
The flowers are gorgeous. I never learned to appreciate small things like these until you came along
The flowers are gorgeous I never learned to- okay. All right, read that okay
Let's go to Swain's Lane. I remembered that Swain's L- owhh
I remember now.
You died a while ago, and I've been denying it since
But you wouldn't want that would you? Me, stuck in my head, living a fantasy
There's so much more of reality to explore. The cat you left me. The flower fields that passed the metro...
Loved you, you know, you left me behind I don't blame you for leaving
Every day, I wake up and think about joining you.
Oh that's heavy. There's only one choice for me
There's no givin' in as is this is a hard fast rule. It's something that is completely against my character, but it's tough
But I'll keep living with the memories you gifted me without you
I think that's one of the endings
Dedicated to everyone who's lost anyone. Thanks for playing
It was so short, it was so sweet.
Oh, but that's not the only ending
That's not the only ending
Oh man, that's tough, it always is losing someone
Especially if it was someone that close to you
But let's explore the game a little further and then I'll make some judgments toward the end of it. Get out of bed
Oh, the flowers are still there. That's weird. I can't even go to Swain's Lane. Let's go anywhere. I'll go anywhere
I don't care where as long as it's far away from home, hours pass. I don't know where I am
I don't know why I'm here
We used to have fun taking the metro together and leaving at random stops
Without you, there is no fun. Without you, repeating old memories just makes me feel lost
By the end of the adventure, I feel like I left a little of my soul at every place I visited
The park, a hill, inside rooms, outside buildings, noisy streets, soft-spoken alleys
night finally falls
When I get back on the bus to head home, no one's there
The loneliness is suffocating
Oh wow
Two sides of an unfair coin
Live and die. Those are two of the five endings
More of a succinct to abrupt end to that story
So there's got to be like apparently it seems like a lot of it has to do with where you go
In uh, in the world, but maybe it has something to do with like the other interactions that you have. Not that you have a lot
Let's go to work. Oh
Oh no. Oh god. It's the crushing monotony of an Amazon Fulfillment Center
Oh no
Do I get to interact with this? No, I guess I don't. Aight roof oh, oh no
Maybe those are the only like two endings just the circumstances are different you live or you die
But then this one in particular the the living one is remembering
I'm honestly kind of curious. I- i know it's probably not
Terribly good, but there must have been a reason to get
like the keys
The phone doesn't work right now. Let me try talking to the kitty
Getting that all sorted. Alright, so we talked to the kitty you make me happy
Love you, too. Let's see about the phone
Huh? I still can't look at the phone. Dunno why, you just can't look at the phone anymore. That's weird. Oh
I can't go to Swain's Lane either. I wonder why it's kind of disabled now. Let's go to the clinic
Observe. The doctors always look so happy with what they're doing
It makes it that much easier to spill every thought you have to them, but I can't tell the truth
I don't know. How how can I when I don't want to remember, wait in line I wait for a very long time
Just as I was beginning to lose hope they finally called my name
Sorry about the wait, our latest experiment in Happiness didn't go quite as well as planned so I had to do some crisis intervention
Enough about me. What can I do for you today?
Let's see. How do I get out of this world? Excuse me. Can you repeat that?
How do I get out of this world? Sorry, I'm not trained to help you with that
Oh
Signs of psychosis possible insanity. Oh don't mind me. I'm just taking notes. Did you need anything else?
My mask is cracking. It looks fine to me
Can I try something else instead? Let me see, would you like to try our newly patented
Happy pills? One day will keep the sadness at bay
Sounds great. Thank you. Of course let us know about your experience. See you around
Alright, i guess go home
Home I guess I can go to Swain's Lane now, which is weird
Still can't read that
Take happy pills
I want to forget about bad thoughts, so that I'm only filled with the good
With every pill I feel myself lose grip of reality a little more. Remember a little less. I need to forget it all
To forget it all I'll take it all
I'm sorry
That's rough, this is all rough. I mean the thing about this is it's it's a story about something
That's not inherently good
like the the thing about this game and the thing about the content that it's trying to talk about is that
It's not a good situation
Like there's no right answer about
Like, how to get to a point where you can, rationalize it or you can, you can understand it
it's it's about accepting something that's completely out of your control, which is something that
No one likes no one no one wants to do. I
Mean I've lost people, and I've known people that have lost more than I have and many, many have lost more than I have
But, y'know
Oh, that's so weird wait, I still have my happy pills
Wait, is this all persistent that's why the flowers were still there. That's why I can't look at my phone anymore. I
I'll talk to the moon
Wonder if there's- the moon has new jokes every once in a while. I
Know it's been hard
What's loud and sounds like an apple? AN APPLE!
I know you want to give up
What class did Karl Marx struggle with the most?
The bourgeois.
What's Brown and rhymes with snoop?
Dr. Dre.
Do you feel alone?
What do you call a dog that does magic tricks?
a Labracadabrador.
I didn't mean to leave you
What word would mean a lot to you right now?
plethora
What's the difference between a well-dressed man on a unicycle and a poorly dressed man on a bike?
Attire
Ylegh, what did you forget?
Who did you forget, what happened to them?
The moon is silent
Child, you're relentless. You have tired me. I need a nap
What are the humans feeding their offspring these days? Tide Pods, was it?
The moon is napping peacefully.
Oh, I guess napping peacefully. Let's go back to work. And then let's go home and we're done
Talk. Do I have to socialize like a full functioning human?
yesterday you said oh
Oh Boy, oh, hey. Hey, how's it going? Oh, hey, what's up? Why are you at work today?
Socializing Oh, why do you ask I mean I just...  Why are you here?
You've been taking this day off for weeks now ever since, uh, I mean
Anyway, why are you here?
I just wanted to.
You wanted to? You okay? You right in the head?
Let's see
I'm fine. Why do you ask?
I really think you should talk to someone, bottling up emotions just doesn't, you know
What do you mean by that? I mean you've been to Highgates, right
Um, Yes?
uh? oh-
Okay, well I just want to say I can go with you if you go- I know from experience that the first time is scariest
Is that a challenge oho boy. Not one. I can beat.
I'm glad I talked to you. We rarely talk. We need to change that
Hmm. Don't feel any better for a report.
Oh, uh, ueh, eh , owhkay
Hi, oh boy. Hello
Alright,
And a decent job as always, of course, there's always room for improvement
Hey, what do you say about working late tonight? Hey, you can improve and I can give you a closer feedback.
I don't want to improve packaging boxes. There's a great opportunity for you. Trust me on this. Ah
No, thanks. You sure? you, me, alone
Is coercing legal. Yeah, I don't know how I got him off my back, but I did just another long long day
Alright go home, I guess
Swain's Lane, I remember now. I've been here before
Yea, i have.
Every day, I wake up and think about joining you
I think I get the point of this game and why it's persistent
Because the point is and the reason that it's persistent is that it's an everyday battle
Like it's it's a desire to fight every day. You don't just wake up one day and be like, I accept it.
I'm done. I'm over it. I I'm good. I'm
I'm stronger than that, I feel strong about it
Like that's not what it's about, like loss stays with you for your entire life
Like it can heal and you'll be fine. You'll, you'll be better for it, but you'll always remember it and like
The temptation to give in is always gonna be there
And it'll always pull you back
that's why you got to stay strong because you know
You survived one day
you can survive more, and you can keep going and then you can keep living, even if it can't seem like you will
I know it's hard, and I'm not the best person to give advice about this
but I knew that this game was gonna be serious and I knew that it was going to
tackle some pretty heavy topics of death
but
if there's one thing I know, and there's one thing that I said the beginning of this video is that
It's not in my nature to ever give in and I could hit this button, and you know, i would see like
I would see another ending that I haven't been seen before but for me personally
I'm never gonna hit that button. Not ever
So I'm gonna choose to survive again. But i'll keep with it with the memories you gifted me without you
Yeah, that is tough, it really is, it's really tough
There's nothing that I can say or do that makes it easier,
and there's no advice that I could give any of you who are going through loss right now,
But you're just knowing that it does get easier
It really does and it's not easier because you forget how important they were to you
It's easier because you appreciate all the good times that you shared together,
and you appreciate all the memories that you have, I mean this game articulates it very well
Like you remember the things that they leave behind, and you remember the lessons that they taught you
The moments that you shared, and the laughs that they gave you even the frustrating times
you know the bad times you remember those too and that's not a bad thing because that's
Literally what life is all about it's about good. It's about bad. It's about sharing experiences with other people,
and that never ends until it does, and you don't know when it's gonna happen, You don't know if it's gonna happen.
Well, I mean, we all know "it's" definitely gonna happen, but you don't know when so
the only advice I can give is to
do as much as you can for the people around you for those that you love to spread as much joy as possible and
Don't like, admonish yourself for any bad times that do happen
But do learn to forgive both others and yourself
when you can.
So anyway, I'll leave this one here if you want to see what that ending is
I'll leave a link to this game in the description below. But just I know given the subject that this is, I
Literally can't press that button. I hope you understand that about me. I just can't because it's not in my nature
I've learned a lot about myself over the years that I've been an "adult" and
part of that comes with, you know, a lot of life lessons that I didn't choose to experience, but did anyway so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
If you are going through any pain right now reach out to someone else in the community who has gone through the same thing
there's tons of people out there and there's huge support groups out there that are ready to talk about it and help you and
Help you through things like loss and pain and depression. So
Just reach out where you can and know that if you are not going through that and you see someone reaching out for help
Why don't you send them some positivity and just send them an encouraging message
So thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you thought down in the comments,
and as always I'll see you
in the next video
Bye-bye
[OUTRO]
[Like, Comment, Subscribe]